bonjour et bienvenue sur mafart sense
donc il ya quelques jours il y avait le
festival vidéo science au carrefour du
numérique à la cité des sciences c'était
un super événement et merci aux
organisateurs d'avoir organiser tout ça
tavant pierre valentini tania au final
c'était pas vraiment une
un festival autre café un festival grand
public c'était plus une espèce de
réunions entre différents vidéaste
scientifique est également des acteurs
de la vulgarisation scientifique au sens
large dans des institutions de
vulgarisation scientifique comme
l'institut henri poincaré où tout ce qui
est mu et scientifique est ce que
c'était vraiment très très intéressant
comme plante n'a pu partager tous nos
bons tuyaux et tous nos déboires et nos
galères tanoh epic fail
mais c'était aussi surtout pour moi
l'occasion de me rendre compte d'un truc
que je savais déjà plus ou moins mais de
remettre un peu une couche sur le fait
qu'être youtuber scientifique c'est la
galère c'est envoie la grosse grosse
galère pour la quasi-totalité des
youtube scientifiques y compris certains
qu'on peut considérer comme assez gros
aujourd'hui en particulier ce qui nous a
permis de faire un peu le point sur ma
situation prospective est clairement je
suis le dernier à plaindre
j'ai une chance inouïe sais pas d'où ça
vient mais j'ai ce job là qu'il m'a été
offert par le pel ou c'est la chance de
faire des vidéos quasiment dans un cadre
quasiment le même que celui dans lequel
je faisais mes vidéos sensor voir à
quelques trucs en mieux comme par
exemple avoir un bureau mais globalement
je suis un globe de répondre aux et je
remercie tous ceux qui sont à le pfl et
qui supporte ce problème mais c'est pas
le cas de la de beaucoup d autres
vidéaste scientifique pour beaucoup
c'est une grosse galère est en fait
facebook des vidéos science s'est
remplie de gens qui sont soit qui font
leurs vidéos et qui entre temps son
soient étudiants soient chômeurs soit en
situation précaire avec un cdd soit
avez-vous avec des contrats ponctuels ou
encore il ya des gens qui font des
vidéos sur leur temps libre sur le peu
de temps libre qu'ils ont parce que
généralement
enfin quand même pas mal de hauts
diplômés vidéo science du coup il ya pas
mal de gens des médecins qui travaillent
ou des ingénieurs qui travaillent toute
la journée
et quand ils font ils vont ils arrivent
à trouver dans leurs temps libres du
temps pour faire des vidéos youtube et
ça c'est à dire que la plupart d'entre
nous cette activité youtube
le fait de faire ces vidéos youtube est
en fait une activité très déficitaire
car on perd beaucoup plus d'argent
investir dans les dents le matériel dans
les caméras matériels sont les
ordinateurs quand arrivent tous à queue
en profite enfin les profits sont
vraiment vraiment négligeable
edit eu loris tu es dit qu'une faible en
général les trois voies en gros
classiques de financement que l'on
pourra avoir c'est ont fait des le
financement participatif avec tipis qui
marche bien pour les gros youtuber très
très gros youtuber mais pour la
quasi-totalité entre le ccdh négligeable
et même pour les eaux grasses et qui est
pourtant un des très très très gros
issue à ce qu est le plus gros vide et à
s'enfuir en termes de nombre d'abonnés
donc de vue au festival vidéo science
même lot grâce elle gagne à peine plus
que le smic
via ce financement participatif quoi il
ya d'autres voies fille de financement
une autre voie de financement c'est à
des contrats d ponctuelles qui avait
plusieurs vidéos de vidéos science qui
ont eu des contrats avec des ministères
ou des institutions pour faire des
vidéos ou pour avec des laboratoires on
mettre en avant certains chercheurs mais
sont des projets qui sont pas toujours
payé pas toujours à rentre rarement très
rarement bien payés et surtout ce sont
des premiers uniquement aux ponctuelles
dont qui empêche tellement de travail au
préalable juste pour arriver à un accord
ou
on peut commencer à paris vidéo que
finalement c'est c'est pas c'est pas
durable et puis enfin il ya la
monétisation des vidéos sur youtube mais
ça peut dire que c'est madame epsilon
c'est négligeable même liot grasset
disait que ça représentait que quelques
centaines d'euros à peine pour lui avec
sa chienne aussi énorme
alors vous imaginez que la quasi
totalité des vidéos ce scientifique
vous serrez que c'est nul
bref au final du coup le festival vidéo
science ça ressemblait beaucoup pour moi
un workshop entretenue entre thésards
c'est à dire ils sont des gens qui ont
très peu de moyens qu'ils ont pourtant
qui sont pourtant extrêmement talentueux
qui ont énormément de diplôme d'
expertise de connaissances et de
compétences dire faire une vidéo youtube
c'est quand même attendant une vidéo de
sciences sur youtube ça requiert
vraiment des compétences à c'est
extrêmement rare et d'ailleurs si vous
en point vous pouvez voir les premières
vidéos faites par nous tous comme
n'importe lequel d'entre nous vous allez
voir que les premières vidéos sont
toujours à mes chiens ou vous créez une
nette progression
tout ça pour dire que le métier tout cas
la capacité à faire des vidéos youtube
scientifique de qualité
c'est une compétence extrêmement
extrêmement rare et ça s'apprend pas du
jour au lendemain la parlent fort
d'entre nous ce sont des années
d'expérience de vulgarisation
scientifique
moi personnellement ça fait 4 4 5 ans
que fait la vulgarisation sur le web et
pour beaucoup des gros hits eu lieu hors
devient pas bon le guardian heures sur
youtube du jour au lendemain en un
claquement de doigts il ya vraiment
moins de son personnes peut-être une
cinquantaine de personnes en france qui
ont cette capacité à expliquer les
choses simplement et efficacement sous
le format youtube de sorte que ça soit
vu par beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
gens et le succès que mon avis des
scientifiques est juste monstrueux alors
j'ai entendu dire que michael et venait
à eddy une fois qu'une ce qui est parce
que son nombre de vues avait dépassé 30
vue ils trouvaient ça fout parce que
c'était une salle de classe
je pense que vraiment on se noie
vraiment dans la monstruosité des
chiffres qui sont sur youtube ces
millions ou ses dizaines de milliers à
chaque fois des camps quand on y
réfléchit
38 c'est déjà énorme et quand on a quand
on est un youtube heures qui a une
centaine de vue comme ce fut le cas pour
pour nous tous moi moi ça va durer des
mois
quelques centaines d'abonnés et de vue
on a l'impression d'être de la merde
parce que presque de leur typologie à
1000 fois puisque nous sommes pourtant
si on on essaie de relativiser ces
chiffres quand on essaie de réfléchir
vraiment à ces chiffres
trois sont vus c'est déjà énorme chaîne
à 1000 abonnés c'est déjà un truc énorme
se retrouver sur scène avec avec la
tronche-en-biais avec kevin de malade
mental où ils disaient qu'on n'y avait
pas de grosses chaînes sur sur la scène
alors que malade mental et et à ton font
guère des dizaines de milliers de
chiffres exacts mais je crois de 30000
et 50 mille abonnés dire que c'est des
petites chaînes ridicule parce que c'est
des grosses chaînes sa touche énormément
énormément de gens peu le prénom c'est
qu'on leur porte toujours sa à des
choses que lequel on est plus familier
comme on tombe plus facilement sur des
chaînes avec vraiment vraiment beaucoup
d'abonnés comparativement on a
l'impression que des chaînes comme
malade mental at on s'engueule son petit
alors que nantes on pense à des chaînes
youtube qui ont des milliers d'abonnés
chaque vidéo fait des milliers voire des
dizaines de milliers de vues en langue
de chat ou ou lanternes cosmique ou
kinect chacune de leurs vidéos touche
des milliers ou voir des dizaines de
milliers de personnes
si on compte ça en nombre de
d'élèves qui a eu un professeur au cours
de toute sa carrière
c'est comparable c'est-à-dire une vidéo
de ces gens là c'est l'équivalent du
nombre de touches de personnes touchées
par un professeur pendant toute sa
carrière c'est monstrueux alors on
pourrait dire oui ou non le professeur
en plus de sa carrière chaque élève il
l'a vu plusieurs heures par semaine
pendant plusieurs mois
du coup on pourrait penser que l'impact
du professeur et plus grands
nécessairement que l'impact de chacun de
ces vidéastes sur quelqu'un dehors mais
je suis pas sûr que cela soit le cas
parce que le public déjà est très
différente
hier le professeur il va tout uniquement
tous chez des élèves d'un certain âge
alors que nous vide à son est capable de
toucher plupart du temps ces tranches
d'âge entre 30 entre 18 et 35 ans c'est
une tranche d'âge qui n'a aucun plus
aucun contact d'études très peu de
contacts parce qu'ils vont à
l'université avec l'académique
l'enseignement l'esprit critique la
réflexion la curiosité et les sciences
en général ou les mathématiques dans mon
cas les mains et les la linguistique les
sciences l'histoire tout ce que vous
voulez qu'il fasse
je pense qu'il y assez c'est comme la
musculation se dire c'est bien beau d'en
avoir fait quand on avait 15 ans 16 ans
mais si on arrêtait de pratiquer pendant
un an au cours des 20 dernières années
ça se sent on est plus en forme on est
plus on a perdu notre forme physique et
dans le cas des sciences de l'histoire
on a perdu notre sensibilité notre
compréhension des concepts importants de
l'histoire des sciences du franc ce que
vous voulez quoi et le gros problème de
l'éducation nationale c'est qu'elle ne
tout ce que les gens jusqu'à 18 ans or
les gens qui votent généralement alors
moyenne d'âge c'est plus dans les
quarante cinq ans et puis l'autre truc
c'est qu'on est dans un contexte
complètement différent qui permet de
parler des mathématiques ou des sciences
ou de linguistique ou de ce que vous
voulez de façon très différente de
manière dont s'est accordé à l'école par
exemple pour le prendre un festival
vidéo sans j'ai été touché record prime
ne serrez et vive voir et il m'a dit que
je ferrais changé sa vision des maths
montré qu'en fait il y avait plusieurs
mathématiques c'est un truc qu'on
n'apprend pas du tout à l'école et qu'on
plusieurs façons de penser les
mathématiques également et là j'ai eu un
impact si aucun de ses professeurs n'a
pu transmettre parce que quand on est
professeur on est contraint par un
certain programme on doit faire bachoter
les élèves et je sais et j'ai enseigné
et je rêvais et mains liées quand j'ai
enseigné j'étais incapable de faire ce
que je fais sur scène ce soir donc
l'impact que je peux avoir sur scène son
rôle est tout autre et très très
complémentaires sont très très
différentes
absolument pas redondant par rapport à
l'impact qu'ont pu avoir les professeurs
dans un cadre difficile quoi bref ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est que l'impact
qu'ont les youtuber scientifique
aujourd'hui il est inégalée mais je
pense même qu'il est inégalable
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on vit une
période peut-être que l'information est
peut-être encore plus importante que
jamais vu la vitesse à laquelle elle
circule et les noyaux de les fils
torball bolze les ai mis la manière dont
l'information se répercutait du coût des
idées fausses peuvent se propager très
rapidement dans un dans un tel milieu
aujourd'hui j'ai beau réfléchir c'est
une question me suis beaucoup vous poser
comment lutter contre ça comment lutter
contre la montée du climato sceptisme ou
de l'homéopathie tous les trucs comme ça
qu'ils ont des gros échec des gros
conséquences sociétales majeures qui
nous implique tous s'il y en a deux
vacciner ça met en danger toute la
population 6 5% à vocation à deux de se
faire vacciner sa mère- engrangé toute
la population du coup ce sont des gros
problèmes et comment lutter contre
contre ça comment
lutter contre l'extrémisme plus
généralement la police la réalisation
des idées entre le déni des sciences le
stéréotype erroné ou les arguments
fallacieux comment lutter contre tout ça
aujourd'hui je ne vois que youtube
je ne vois que les youtuber scientifique
et je pense que plus généralement tous
les youtuber qui culturels scientifiques
qui font du partage certaines valeurs
une valeur de réflexion d'esprit
critique de curiosité dans vie de bien
faire en général et plus d'humilité
tous ces youtuber qui partagent ces
valeurs doivent être mis plus en avant
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est youtuber
scientifiques ou culturelles qui
partagent ses valeurs
je pense très très très importante pour
nos sociétés pour le futur de nos
sociétés voire de l'humanitaire je pense
qu'il faut absolument supporter ces gens
là faut vraiment absolument les
encourager et les finances et les mettre
dans des conditions ils seront capables
de produire se voir de contenu de façon
régulière avec la qualité et la quantité
dont on aimerait qu'ils fassent preuve
quand je vois la tronche longuet balade
mental ou le senso vandor qui sont des
chaînes mais incroyablement bien bien
fait bien script est bien réalisé et
bien montée bien bien foutu et qui
partagent bien expliqué qu'ils partagent
des valeurs qui sont promouvoir beaucoup
davantage
et quand je vois que les auteurs de ces
chaînes là sont en galère financière en
galère de carrière ni c'est désolant pts
c'est vraiment dommage que ses talons
lacés gens qui ont vraiment un talent
rare et qui sont capables d'atteindre
déjà un public énorme c'est vraiment pas
normal c'est désolant
ces gens là ne soit pas capable de
continuer librement avec le soutien
qu'ils mériteraient à faire ce qu'ils
font et le tdr de tous à ce que
j'aimerais vraiment que vous reteniez
tout ça c'est que
ces gens là ont vraiment vraiment besoin
dead et je vous demande pas forcément
d'aller leur faire des dons sur tipi ce
que je pense qu'il faut que ça soit un
truc beaucoup plus gros qui les supporte
si je vous remercie tous les types
heures et où vous faites des trucs
géniaux mais je pense que l'aide doit
venir de plus haut aujourd'hui le budget
de l'éducation nationale se comptant en
dizaines de milliards d'euros
j'avais lu 65 milliards d'euros aux
quelque part donnez nous un million de
ses 65 milliards ccc moins de 1 pour 10
milles si vous donnez sa vidéo sciences
vous au café des sciences qui regroupe
aussi les bloqueurs les dessinateurs et
les podcasteurs scientifique du web si
quelque part ils pouvaient avoir un
million d'euros qui traînait pour vidéo
science ça permettrait à tellement de
talent de continuer à faire de mieux
faire tousser qui sont en train de faire
et ça permettrait de bien mieux lutter
contre l'obscurantisme et et tous les
pseudo science et tout ça avec des
valeurs des vidéos qui promeuvent la
curiosité l'esprit critique et tout ça
il faut pas juste se concentrer
d'ailleurs sur les vidéos juste de
zététique je trouve que les idéaux de
zététique sont géniales très bien fait
et font super mais s'il faut lutter
contre toutes les pseudo science et tout
ça je pense que ça suffit pas ce que je
pense que lorsqu'une seule chaîne jazz
s'annonce et éthiques
mais déjà un petit mur elle s'annonce
déjà d'une certaine manière qui va
peut-être rebuter certains viewers alors
qu'enfin des trucs que moi j'aime bien
faire et que je pense beaucoup de
youtube heure et demie à faire notamment
une youtuber plus matheux s'est parlé de
quelques sujets qui ont l'air anodin et
puis à la fin on va dire à dire mais en
fait c'étaient des mathématiques et
tient en fait ça me permet de repenser
quel truc et ça va nous permettre aussi
de repenser tel point que dans votre
quotidien et petit à petit donc on
essaie plus de piéger parfois les gens à
faire des mathématiques contre leur gré
bref je pense qu'il ya énormément de
vecteurs
pour promouvoir la curiosité l'esprit
critique et tout ça et qu'il faut
vraiment supporté tout où tous ces
mouvements tous et toutes ces superbes
chaîne youtube qui aujourd'hui me semble
être la meilleure arme que l'on est à
notre disposition pour lutter contre les
idées qui pourraient être néfastes
néfaste à notre à nos sociétés je pense
qu'il faut vraiment supporter les
vidéastes scientifique tout en leur
donnant la même liberté qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils font très très
très bien ils font ça beaucoup mieux que
nous que ferait n'importe quelle
institution et si on commençait à
vouloir institutionnaliser ce qu'ils
font si vous mettez des barrières entre
leur temps de production entre
l'écriture de leur script et moment et
sort ses découragerait beaucoup et ça
énerve loukouss des 4es la qualité des
vidéos qu'ils font il faut essayer de
trouver un moyen de financer tous ces
gens là de leur assurer une certaine
sécurité financière voire un bien-être
financier parce que ces gens là le
mérite vraiment et tout en leur
garantissant une certaine liberté qui
leur permettrait de continuer à produire
les de la qualité et peut-être même
mieux en quantités notamment que ce
qu'ils font à l'heure actuelle je pense
que c'est une question de futur de nos
sociétés je pense que future d'une
société est en jeu
certaine manière je pense que c'est
extrêmement important que les très bons
youtuber scientifique que j'ai mentionné
tout cette vidéo il y en a encore
d'autres j'ai pas finniste complète à
aller voir vidéo six ans en général pour
tous les voir je pense que c'est très
important que ces gens là soient
supportés dans leurs efforts
parce que leurs efforts et peut-être
l'un des métiers les plus éthiques qui
soit aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle bref
c'était marie force ça vaut ce que ça
vaut est votre avis compte au moins
autant que le mien donc vous invite à le
mettre dans les commentaires